après trois jours d'incertitude la
mission de Joe Biden était claire
rassurer les Américains et les
investisseurs sur la solidité du système
bancaire des États-Unis si l'école
Valley Bang qui ferment ses portes
vendredi une autre appelée signature à
New York soumise au même traitement
dimanche la crainte d'une contagion est
élevée et rappelle jusqu'à un certain
point la crise de 2008 ou le système
bancaire américain s'est écroulé comme
un château de cartes et a poussé
l'administration Obama a sauvé à coup de
3600 milliards de dollars une industrie
déjà un populaire pas question de faire
la même chose cette fois-ci tranche Joe
Biden
ne sera financée par l'argent des
contribuables l'argent préviendra des
frais que les banques versent au fond
d'assurance dépôt et il ajoute
ses banques mal gérées seront limogé et
quant à ceux qui ont investi dans ces
entreprises ils ne seront pas indemnisés
ils ont tout risqué les pertes sont à
leur dépend
la faillite de la Silicon valley-ban
serait principalement dû à ses choix
d'investissement intrinsèquement liés au
taux d'intérêt les récentes Hauses
décrétées par la Réserve fédérale ont
plongé la banque dans l'eau chaude sa
fermeture ne serait pas un ancien triste
d'une réaction en chaîne croisée
analyste
ne faisait affaire que dans un seul
domaine avec les entreprises de haute
technologie dit-il cela ne concerne que
peu de particulier ce matin à la banque
signature de New York les clients
étaient inquiets
je ne reviens pas de celui-ci et c'est
notoire
ils m'ont rassuré dit ce client grâce à
la protection des dépôts annoncés par
Joe Biden les marchés aussi de mer
inquiets et surveillent les autres
petites et moyennes banques dans
l'espoir que la situation ne dégénère
pas davantage le spectre de 2008 n'est
jamais très loin mais tant du côté
démocrate que républicain l'appétit pour
un autre sauvetage bancaire n'est pas du
tout au rendez-vous
on ne peut pas toujours sauver ses
compagnies privées qui ont fait des
erreurs expliquent cette républicaine
elles doivent en accepter les
conséquences ces faillite aurait pu être
évité croient certains démocrate Joe
Biden va donc demander aux autorités de
régulation bancaires de renforcer ses
règles des règles qui avaient été
implantées après la crise de 2008 et qui
avait ensuite été modifié à la baisse
par l'administration Trump ici frédéric
Arnould Radio-Canada à Washington